jimmy on se retrouve sur la première
pour confiner d'ici et d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs je suis moi même confiné dans
nos salons mais ça ne nous empêche pas
de voyager la preuve c'est
qu'aujourd'hui je vous emmène aux états
unis on part à la rencontre de patricia
malidor coleman une martiniquaise qui
vit du côté de boca en floride
depuis à peu près 40 ans bonjour
patricia très bien merci nous faire
voyager parce qu'on n'a pas beaucoup
l'occasion en plein confinement de
pouvoir voir un peu de monde on est ravi
d'être avec toi aujourd'hui patricia tu
trouves pas loin de miami joint aux
retraités dans ta voiture tu es où
exactement dans quel restaurant et salle
à des choses super super bo est simple
donc ça c'est très très très importante
donc comment sur l'application est
normalement ils sont tenus par deux
trois fois c'est très vite les
applications cinq minutes vous envoie le
message que si les américains ils
s'adaptent de toute façon on l'a vu la
crise est particulièrement dur chez vous
avec le commis 19 mai les américains ont
cette capacité aussi à rebondir à faire
quand même avec a continué à travailler
à faire malgré tout c'est ce que tu
ressens toit du côté de miami ou pas
loin voilà ce qu'a fait cette chaleur
cette can c'est cette valeur des dettes
[Musique]
sur cgpi aller de l'avant aussi fait
beaucoup d'optimisme ses malheurs aux
petits on connaît pas les nouvelles
continuent comme avant ça on voit des
gens avec des gants et des masques sion
c'est comme ça du 40e
un peu plus de 40 ans que tu vis aux
états unis qu'est ce qui t'a amené là
bas parce que je rappelle que tu es
martiniquaise d'origines différents
trouvait aux états unis pourquoi comment
tu lui fais quoi dans cette manche
d'avancé laporte l'amérique latine
caraïbes
comme j'aimais beaucoup l'anglais
l'espagnol et dans les affaires
internationales et dense est parti de
mes études je n'avais les enfants
américains
qu'est ce qui est différent j'imagine
qu'il ya de grandes différences entre
les états unis le système français la
façon de fonctionner la façon de penser
qui toujours que très souvent quand on
recherche quelque chose de différent et
sentiments françois pervis s'est pas
trop bagages et l'éducation par exemple
l'américain donc voilà la différence
mais je trouve que j'ai beaucoup de
chance d'avoir les deux parce que sans
les deux je serais pas allé jusqu'au
bout d'avoir moins inquiet d'avoir la
société qui aura 25 ans l'année
prochaine il ya quand même une façon de
penser cette double nationalité cette
double culture permettent vraiment
d'être travailleuses
est-ce que tu arrive quand même à
travailler malgré ce contexte
particulier toi qui évolue aussi dans
tourisme dans la formation justement
est-ce que tu as exception devraient
pouvoir continuer à voir l'activité
rebondit énormément aux états unis wen
de dix jours toutes vos publicités vont
changer
c'est à dire que l'américain tout de
suite j'ai dit voilà bien ce problème
qu'est ce qu'on va faire
est ce qu'on offre à notre consommateur
mentalité du consommateur n'a une
mentalité de compétition et donc pas là
dessus
et moi j'ai pu faire exactement la même
chose donc merci société et si wade
travaille avec déjà des jeunes qui
viennent s'installer aux états-unis ou
ailleurs
d'ailleurs pour faire leurs études à
avoir fait trembler les brigades adultes
viennent vivre aller travailler donc aux
états unis ou à l'étranger donc chez le
ch en fait j'ai des expats de déjeuner
ou qui n'ont pas pu rentrer chez eux qui
en fait surface c'est déjà avec cultures
différentes façons de faire différentes
une langue et où évoluent et en plus
cette crise qui est pour l action
culturelle globale 1 donc pour moi ça va
vous changer sauf que je crois que la
vie n'est qu'une fois par semaine à peu
près et du coup plus ambitieux de
console comme avec toi maintenant j
alors ou téléphone tout le temps ce qui
veut dire que je te connais tu sais pas
j'étais un tout un moment pour marcher
dans la nature sont les dernières
peuvent le faire faire une petite
méditation publié au caire pour
rencontrer des amis est censé faire est
ce qu'il ya un coin en particulier que
tu peux nous conseillerais en disant il
faut absolument découvrir celle des
années 1930 d'antigua scouts historique
grâce à l'architecturé qu'il ya aussi le
côté moderne
merci beaucoup patricia malidor coleman
pour pour ce petit voyage à miami depuis
ta voiture alors y avoir que tu sortes
pour vous faire quand même voir un peu
la rouille
non
voilà super merci en tout cas
patricia malidor coleman c'est un
plaisir d'échanger avec maman on te
laisse retourner prendre de quoi manger
bien évidemment et on espère te voir
très bientôt du côté de la floride
merci encore
[Musique]